welcome to the video I'm playing
sauerkraut again played him so off
recently get a no-no an exchange
exchange calc on thought you place the
that one's okay so what am I going to do
is a play Bishop f5 at some point and
then exchange LightSquared bishop trying
to when II form as a good square for my
pieces so here we go
94 this is the idea one possibility even
is king H a drupe g8 Bishop f6 tried to
play on the G file in general this whole
line the Sun is rather unambitious for
white oh wait not not too quickly I mean
I try to avoid the the worst time
scrambles but you take this unknown Jade
ok so I thought that this would be nice
93 as a threat and isn't this isn't this
a good position anyway go into here now
it sets active the idea is to play 93
tactic tactical shops 93 Queen d3 Queen
fo and if I get this night exchanged
again the bishop then the dark square
should be should be excellent for me and
I really like the position very much
already
yeah 93 is there a reason not to play
this maybe Bishop g3 okay but I want to
double here anyway the night always has
this retreating option as well
hmm
yeah this looks nice but is it doing
much my whole position I mean I don't
don't know yeah the Knights if I want to
get get some something serious going
here I need to get the Knights involved
let's let's try to regrow
I've various ideas one idea is to play
deform maybe it's a it's too ambitious
but let's let's do that and do it
quickly I want to get the knight on d5
to have squares for for for the for the
night Oh interesting he just just de
plexiform I didn't think about that at
all
I isn't is terribly dangerous for you
like d3 and let's get just advancium not
spent ages I'm getting really active now
how to how to break through him like
activate stuff 94
hmm it's not threaten English okay
okay this is some super ambitious maybe
I just bad but ok got limited time
now this I didn't didn't see it all
ok
now if he takes takes on f6 I cannot
take on f6 but I didn't think it was so
so much of a problem maybe it is in fact
but my bishop d6 yeah and f6 was very
ambitious
no I didn't I didn't consider that at
all ah very very sure
huh yeah he just promotes this okay
black resigned of a shame I mean I was
well okay let's ask the come first black
is completely winning I wasn't too
optimistic a four wins everything wins I
mean white is completely outplayed this
is easy to see actually but f6 was just
just a really nonsense idea just just
protect here and then continue to
improve the position I mean he's just
reduced to two passive positions here
but f6 was was too much maybe it is ya
know and now be six is still playable
but I didn't I simply didn't see that
he's got f 79 Bishop p6 I mean I thought
I'd get it back end its ok but yeah I
was very surprised that he played c4
it's frankly speaking just the barrels
giving me all those positional acid cm
so it's a bit much
yeah I round here Oh brought you two
here wins check could have put a shot on
about that a bit at least but probably I
wouldn't have seen it anyway this is
just just too deep then the computer has
no problem finding all that but check
check yeah and this is too much quite
quite funny how the nights and all this
is better than then the two rooks ok I
hope you enjoyed it anyway thanks for
watching